I tell you the Zebra story,
you,
any of you know that story.
Okay,
I'll tell you this story.
Tell it.
Stop me if I've told it to you before.
This tells you everything you need to
know about human beings.
So it's worth it.
It's worth.
It's worth knowing.
Okay,
so zebras have stripes and people say,
well,
that's for camouflage,
and then you think about that for two
seconds and you think that's a really
stupid theory because lions are
camouflaged and they're like golden,
like the grass and zebras are black and
white,
so you can see a zebra five miles away.
It's like there's a zebra,
it's black and white.
So the whole camouflage thing that's
just not working out so well as a
hypothesis.
Okay.
So bylaw biologists go and they decided
to take a look at some zebras and so
they're looking at zebra at on the herd
because there's no zebra,
right?
Just like there's no fish.
There are schools of fish and there are
herds of zebras.
There isn't a fish.
This is why I think the cod aren't
coming back.
There are no cod.
There are massive hundred mile long
schools of cod,
10 stories deep,
20 million years old.
You wipe out the school.
You don't just get to throw a quad in
the water and say,
well,
you know,
off you go.
It's like,
well,
where's my city?
It's like launching you in the middle of
a field.
It's like,
well,
go out there and reproduced.
It's like,
no,
that's not gonna happen,
you know,
so without the school that there's no
cod and you can't just introduce a whole
school of cod because you don't have a
whole school of cod,
so you know,
maybe the cod are never coming back and
zebras are the same thing there.
There's not a zebra,
there's zebras and so you're looking at
the zebras trying to study as zebra and
you look at the Zebra and you make some
notes and you look up and you think,
oh Christ.
Which zebra was I looking at?
And the answer to that is you don't know
because the,
the camouflage is against the herd and
the black and white stripes.
There's a variety of reasons for this.
Stripes flies also seem not to like the
stripes,
but you know,
usually people,
things evolve for multiple reasons,
but anyways,
it's very difficult to parse out a zebra
against the herd.
You look down,
you look up,
it's like,
oh,
I'll hold those.
Damn zebras look the same.
Yes,
the camouflage is effective,
but it's against the herd.
All right,
so then you think,
well,
we better identify as zebra so we can
see what he's up to.
So then you take your jeep and a can of
red paint and a stick with a rag on the
end of it and you drive up to the zebras
and you paint their haunch.
Read that a little bit,
put a nice red dot on their haunch or
maybe clipped the rear with a cattle
clip and then you stand back and you
think,
Hey,
I'm pretty smart now.
I gotta watch that Zebra.
So what do you think happens to the
Zebra?
The lions kill it,
right?
Right,
right.
Because lions,
they're smart,
right?
Hunter hunting animals are smart,
but they have to identify a zebra before
they can organize their hunt.
They can't just hunt the whole herd.
They have to pick out a zebra and so
maybe it's like a zebra that's got a
sore hip or something and so you think,
well,
nature's kind.
It just takes the week.
It's still no zebra or lions,
like really healthy,
delicious zebras,
but they look like all the other
healthy,
delicious zebras so they can't get a
beat on them.
But if there are small and just born or
if they're limping or there's something
that identifies them,
then the lions can pick them out and
then they do pick them out.
And so the rule for human beings is keep
your damn stripes on so the lions don't
get you.
And I'm telling you,
man,
if you want to remember one thing from
my class about human motivation,
that's a good thing to learn.
People camouflage themselves against the
herd and they like to be in the middle
of the herd,
which is what fish do.
By the way,
if you have a big school of fish,
the smart,
healthy,
large fish are in the middle of the
school because you know what you call a
fish on the outside of the school bait,
right?
So that's what people are doing there
are trying to move into the middle of
the herd all the time and the herd moves
around or the school moves around and
people are going,
well,
I'm in the middle,
I'm staying in the middle here,
so I've got this protective ring of
people around me so the predators don't
pick me out and do me in.
So okay,
so that's part of the reason why I said,
well,
you can't sell something to someone for
success because you're thinking,
well,
people are aiming at success.
Don't,
don't be thinking that.
It's not by any means necessarily true
trait.
Neuroticism is a potential most powerful
motivator and trait.
Neuroticism is let's not be too
threatened or hurt,
right?
That's the negative emotion system.
And the negative emotion system is a
killer source of motivation.
You know,
you also see that there are scales of
wellbeing that have been designed mostly
by social psychologists,
which means they're very bad scales most
of the time because their psychometric
capacity is is is absurdly low,
generally speaking.
So what you find with scales of
wellbeing sometimes they're talked about
as scales of happiness even is that
people aren't after happiness
thereafter,
not hurting.
It's not so they don't want to be
extroverted and enthusiastic,
right and and bubbly and full of smiles
and laughter.
That isn't what they mean by I want to
be happy.
What they mean is I don't want to be
anxious or in pain,
and so wellbeing scales tend to be
something like neuroticism,
sorry,
emotional stability plus extroversion,
but the big loading is on emotional
stability.
The reverse of neuroticism.
You want to avoid suffering.
You don't want to be happy.
You want to avoid suffering,
and one way to avoid suffering is not to
let the Lions Gnaw on you.
And one way of doing that is to stay in
the middle of the damn hurt.
And so like,
I'm not being a smart Alec about this.
I understand why people do that.
There's real danger to being visible.
There's real danger in being visible.
Now.
You might be successful if you're
visible,
but you also might be dead.